messieurs je vous sers une coupe de
champagne parfait il y en a aussi
réveillé mais télé derrière avec les
autres déchets l'eau ou joueurs-clés oui
non
[Musique]
c'est quoi tout ça oui je sais pas m'en
servir
tu vis tu tires matin je sais ce que
c'est c'est le malheur qui est tous les
ans une élite fric et kidnappent des
gens normaux comme nous ou est-ce qui
vous ont enlevé dans le wyoming à
orlando dans le mississippi ce n'est pas
une plaisanterie ils chassent des êtres
humains pour le plaisir
ce ne sont pas des êtres humains vous
désirez on est dans quel état ici en
principe on chez olé les principes c'est
pas mon truc vous êtes dans un bel état
de l'arkansas ma belle vous avez une
question comment tu as su qu'elle
mentait parce que tout le monde ment
[Musique]
mba
ils nous ont pas choisi par hasard je
vais pas me laisser faire
à la guerre comme à la guerre
vous ne savez pas qui vous avez affaire
[Musique]
ce coup ci
ils ont pas choisi la bonne personne
quel mensonge avant ils vont vous
massacrer on verra et 6 ouailles keim a
souvent hibou